how many emails do I send a year maybe
six or seven hundred million the best
business to start is something that
solves your own problem and so for me I
was using MailChimp I've used convertkit
I've checked out a Weber check one I
found him way over expensive
I found him way over complicated to me
like 45 minutes to set up MailChimp
email and so I was like I just want
something more affordable and simpler
and that's why we built Sun Fox and I
think that's something where I'll keep
working on it forever with the team I
think what's interesting is trying to
think about what's gonna happen in the
next six months to six years and then
how do I be a little bit ahead of
everyone else so if you think about it
let me ask you soon do you think there's
gonna be more or less content creators
in the future
absolutely more so I think you know the
one problem that I notice with all the
channels like YouTube or Instagram or
tic toc or any of these is that
ultimately they are incentivized to get
you to pay to talk to your audience why
because they have to make money and so
email is the only channel I've ever
found that can scale communicating with
an audience that you can fully control
and so I think if San Fox becomes the
number one place for people to grow
their audiences one I want it for myself
number one and two is just a really big
and interesting opportunity to work on
so we send how many emails do I send a
year maybe six or seven hundred million
I don't even know to be honest I'm
appSumo probably has a similar amount of
emails like hundreds of millions of
sends per year well I pay I think I pay
10 or 15 grand a month to send those is
it done right I don't really know I
think what there's two things that are
more interesting to me one I've been
focusing more on the total audience that
you have available because email isn't
is a component of your audience right so
you actually have like hustle on
Facebook hustle Instagram hustle YouTube
hustle podcast and your total active
audience and there's overlap that number
I'm actually more fascinated with and
the second thing with email I think the
metric cost is one thing but I think
that we've said said you said said
Fox was trying to make it cheaper
because you're bored of them I don't
like the portable yeah Laura for you
yeah because we have teens
how much is that to cost ascend
like for us mentally it I'll tell you if
you take point zero zero zero two and
then times about how many emails so the
thing that MailChimp and convertkit and
all these guys so point zero zero two
times your number so they make money if
you don't send emails because they make
money off your subscriber of course and
so the way that's so send Fox is free
and then we're a one-time payment
because most people don't actually email
and so we're trying to fix that and work
through those kind of challenges of
people but the other thing I think
people need to think about in terms of
growing their community or starting a
newsletter like if you don't have one
start it today you send Fox comm number
one but the second thing is the number
that's the most important is not your
email list size it is your active email
a size so it is the amount of people
within three months that have open and
clicked your email because you know I've
had hundreds of thousands for all I
think in my total lifetime of okay dork
I've had a hundred and seventy-five
thousand subscribe to the newsletter my
active audience is only 55 think about
that yeah
and that's what we do too but we turn
people every three months like we sunset
them like when we send them an email and
be like hey you're gonna get we're gonna
take you off this list what percentage
is it I don't know off the top of my
head to be honest with you but I know
that like one I could tell you this
though so like our open rates really
really high right now it's like fifty
five percent and I think the average
person saves two years so you could
somehow figure out what that is yeah but
but like like if we don't get them on
the hook right away then they're never
gonna get on the hook how do you gonna
hook your welcome email needs to be
really good your Thank You page after
they sign up needs to be really good you
know this this is what you dude
here's the thing I'm still learning
well you had this even your unsubscribe
page needs to be great which you didn't
you have a really good unsubscribe yeah
but I gave up on that one I think the
Thank You page and you're welcome thing
or like the two of the most neglected
pieces of marketing yeah I call them
like you have to make the Forgotten
parts really good so like your Thank You
page your welcome email your unsubscribe
page just like little Easter Egg
like that that needs to be good but
to make him good yeah well our so I get
accused of stealing CD babies email
welcome email which I didn't even know
what that was but then when I saw it I
realized oh yeah I can I totally
understand why people see this I think I
steal that stole that but my welcome
email was a like a really detailed
welcome email that it was like really
long and explained what happened when
you signed up and it was pretty funny
and like if you google like the hustle
welcome email a lot of people wrote
about it people seem to like that so
just like being creative and writing
long-form content about what happened
after those types of things when those
people signed up it works pretty well
but with so let's say like convertkit
let's say convertkit is doing twenty
million dollars a year in sales which
chimeric it's awesome because i like the
guy who started it I like convertkit and
they reveal all their revenue numbers if
they're doing twenty million in revenue
like you said that you try to make cent
fox more affordable I have no idea how
much do they actually charge thing to or
how much are they what's their cogs in
order to send all those emails
Oh point zero zero two it might be point
zero zero zero one five times how many
subscribed how many emails are sending a
month the profit is all in the people
who don't email it's basically I think
of email marketing companies is very
expensive hosting you're basically
paying a lot of money to host zeros and
ones and digits that don't cost anything
and so I think one importantly if people
are businesses like that's a really
interesting business to start it's also
interesting business to disrupt like I
think sub stack is done amazing with it
coming at it from like hey emails
actually free and we're gonna make money
on the subscription part so you don't
have to pay for email anymore
same with send fox it's like it's mostly
free and we're gonna be focusing we're
focusing more on like youtubers and
podcasters so it's like who are the
audiences that aren't really emailing
enough or don't know how to email for
this specific type of audience I think a
market for that is musician spans I
think there's a huge like if you look at
them money where musicians make it is in
concerts and they're horrible at
notifying you when they're coming into
town well if you any type it type in
right now I was typing some no dude
relax but yeah I think musicians I mean
I think the point though
you have to serve a customer that I
think you have an understanding of I
think a lot of these want renews out
they're like oh yeah let me go help
musicians I'm like one I don't know
about musicians I'm learning to play
piano it's right here
but the point being is like I think we
it's not that you shouldn't go outside
of your comfort zone I just think
there's easier ways of success and I
think more too many people make it too
hard on themselves and it's just like
going to your own problems or going to
problems of people around you that you
have easier access to what about have
you been looking into amp for email yeah
some of this stuff I mean I also you
know there's also talk about hey emails
dying and all this stuff I'm like people
using it left and right I've seen amp
where it's like a little bit more of
dynamic and faster loading emails I
think the most important thing about
email is not necessarily the layouts and
all that stuff I think the most
important thing is how do you build a
relationship where people are expecting
your email we're like if I stopped
emailing or the hustle didn't come
they're like something is wrong with my
day and until you could say that point
you're you're probably worrying about
the wrong problems yeah I mean that's
the hard part
obviously that's like how do you create
I mean that's just about creating good
but I still think the whole amp
thing is actually super interesting what
what I'm working on is a few ways to
hack it because I'm I kind of am
obsessed with like storytelling in email
and so what can you like if you think
about what is a Jif to me a jiff is a
moveable image that has no sound well so
is most of the video that you use on
Instagram on Facebook it's just audio or
it's just a video with no sound like
because a lot of times you don't even
click like listen you know I'm saying
and so what I'm interested is how can I
use amp to tell a story in an email in a
video format or like all these other
hacks like that that's incredibly
interesting to me I think there's
something there with that the thing that
we've been doing with sin Fox that we've
been building in is there's kind of like
two major components that I think are
lacking an email so number one is how do
you build in like what the hustle and
morning brew hobb which is building
referrals so we've basically built that
in so anyone can have their own referral
engine within emails that was a huge
pain in the ass for us I know so we
built it and it works and I'm doing it
on ok so if you gotta send Fox a comp
slash Noah you can see how it looks or
sign up for yourself and it's built in
for free I think the second thing that
we're observing so what everyone wants
is like
do I grow my audience and how do I send
consistent emails because if you're not
sending something weekly you get
forgotten and then this age of attention
we're all fighting for it and so we
built this thing called weekly
newsletter template or week I think
their branding it's smart campaigns and
so the idea there is that we suck in all
of your social information and we look
at what's most popular and then we
basically just like we recommend like
hey here's the three things that you
should email your audience this week and
so that's what I do every Wednesday I
just pull my two of my favorite things
and one of someone else's to try to
spread joy and love and build
relationship with people I don't know
yet
[Music]
[Applause]